est-ce que vous
merci
est ce que vous êtes déjà demandé ce que
vous faisiez si dans ce monde
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit que naître
pour aller à l'école
travailler gagner de l'argent consommer
pour vivre une retraite confortable et
ensuite mourir ensuite n'était pas la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes ici
pour moi ces questions vont habiter
pendant longtemps et je me rappelle même
de moi dans mon enfance
je me réveillais la nuit en pleine
anxiété en disant où est ce que monsieur
lavis un sens
j'ai quand même suivi le chemin
classique qu'est ce que je pourrais bien
faire d'autres
cégep en sciences
et j'étais très bon en mathématiques en
physique donc l'université en ingénierie
c'était la suite logique
à la fin de mes études j'étais prête
pretalli sur le marché du travail
et je me rappellerai toujours de de ce
moment où j'étais assise comme stagiaire
et je me voyaient offrir cet emploi à
temps plein avec des conditions de
travail par fait mon chemin était tout
tracé
ma retraite clairement assuré
puis c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
flanché
je pouvais plus faire semblant
bien cette voie l'intérieur de moi plus
forte que tout qui criait c'est assez
puis quand je vous raconte ça vraiment
l'image revient si c'est celle du
parachutiste en eau dans l'avion qui se
tient comme ça prêt à sauter qui
regardent en voit qui fait au hasard
est-ce que je vais vraiment faire ce pas
ce que fait le plus fou quand même une
histoire le
et après il prend 1 prend un printemps
pour lui quatre ans pour un temps pour
respirer ça sur second j'ai mon
parachute je suis soutenu sans bien
aller je fais confiance en la vie parce
qu'on s'entend j'ai bon j'ai jamais
sauter en parachute concrètement mais
mais j'imagine que cette personne en qui
décide de se lancer dans le vide doit
avoir une foi incroyable on la vit
et bien je vous le dis j'étais
exactement là
au bord du vide
vacillant entre cette peur
de sauter dans le vide et en même temps
cette confiance que ça allait bien aller
et justement quand on décide de faire
pleinement confiance en la vie si à ce
moment là que les portes s'ouvrent
et on décide d'y aller
donc bonjour je m'appelle avrillaise
puis chez je suis ici aujourd'hui pour
vous
dire qu'est ce que ça prend pour changer
notre monde rien de moins
et en toute humilité en fait je vais
vous raconter mon histoire
et les différents clés qui ont été
révélées à travers mon chemin
donc pour revenir à ce saut dans le vide
pour moi ça a été un grand moment de
bascule dans ma vie parce qu'après cinq
années d'études je cherchais encore
je trouvais pas ma place dans ce système
qui me semblait étrange et un système
qui faisaient aucun sens de travailler
cinq jours sur cinq un endroit qui
pensait juste au profit juste à
l'enrichissement
et aucun effet on était dédiée au
respect commun au respect de
l'environnement
donc c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai
ressenti à l'intérieur de moi ce besoin
profond de comprendre le système de
l'analyser et pourquoi pas
commencer à y contribuer en plantant
cette grande nouvelle
c'est irène que j'imaginais voir se
transformer en arbre un arbre en forêt
et une forêt qui porterait cet espoir
l'espoir de voir se transformer notre
façon de concevoir et de réfléchir notre
monde
bon ok dans le temps clairement on
pouvait l'imaginer comme étant très vite
la liste ayant un peu la tête dans les
nuages et aimant beaucoup rêver en grand
et bien aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
content de vous dire que
je suis heureuse d'avoir continuer de
rêver
donc pour moi je te ment ça a été le
moment où j'ai sauvé ma première graine
et j'ai décidé d'aller faire une
maîtrise en gestion de l'innovation
sociale à hec montréal ici même et j'ai
eu la chance de découvrir la
décroissance soutenable
qui mit beaucoup de mots sur son malaise
que je ressentais à l'intérieur et on
pourrait dire que la décroissance à ce
moment là à ce moment là dans mon
processus être ça a été mon parachute
donc qu'est ce qui m'a vraiment soutenu
dans ce changement 4
alors qu'est ce que la décroissance
la décroissance se pose au dogme de la
croissance économique en disant qu'elle
est insoutenable qu'elle creuse les
inégalités
et qu'elle est aliénante on entend
souvent cette phrase qui dit qu'une
croissance infinie dans un monde fini
est impossible
donc pourquoi insoutenable sur le plan
écologique
parce que notre consommation excessive
des ressources non renouvelables une
difficulté à les recycler et les
réutiliser
épuise considérablement les ressources
de notre planète
insoutenable parce que l'ère de
l'industrialisation et des high tech
dans laquelle nous sommes créé de plus
en plus de déchets difficilement
assimilable par les écosystèmes
le rapport du giec de 2021 le dis pour
la première fois avec clarté les
activités humaines sont la principale
cause du réchauffement climatique
le système pose également des enjeux au
niveau de la justice sociale donc est ce
qu'on nous a promis on se dit qu'une
croissance
la croissance allait améliorer le niveau
de vie tous et qu'est ce qu'on observe
réellement
on observe que 80% des richesses de la
planète
sont détenus dans seulement 1% des mains
de la population
on observe aussi une injustice au niveau
des non-humains
replace l'humain au dessus de la nature
au dessus des animaux on parle ici des
tic animal et on a juste à regarder la
façon qu'on produit une nourriture
et finalement la décroissance nomme que
ce système et aliénant ils nous dominent
il nous rend de plus en plus dépendants
de toutes ces technologies omniprésente
est juste un exemple assez assez simple
juste
commencé à imaginer devoir sortir le
matin de votre maison sans votre
téléphone cellulaire
est
presque mission impossible
donc quand j'imagine le monde dans
lequel chouette évolué je pense en fait
à ces trois valeurs
la durabilité en permettant aux
ressources de se renouveler et en
diminuant la création déchets
la justice
en permettant une redistribution des
richesses et des savoirs pour permettre
de les rendre accessibles au plus grand
nombre
et cette émancipation
tendre vers cette autonomie à tous les
niveaux et cette capacité à se gouverner
selon nos propres normes et notre propre
nature
donc avec ces trois valeurs en poche les
gros on est prêt à changer le monde
non mais sincèrement
je suis dieu
mais en fait
par où commencer
puis un ami en fait m'a déjà dit
qu'elle est le plus petit pas proche de
toi que tu puisse réaliser
et je me suis dit waouh c'est un concept
existe réellement parce que bon ça me
semble à fait assez simple est en fait
en faisant quelques recherches j'ai
vraiment découvert
cette méthodologie qu'on appelle la
méthodologie
ppp le plus petit pas possible
donc faire le port débuté par le pôle le
plus simple le plus accessible et je
rajouterais même
commencer par le pôle le plus simple le
plus accident accessible et celui qui
nous amène le plus de joie vraiment se
laisser guider par notre coeur
et sans trop connaître à l'époque sans
trop connaître ce principe je réalise
que c'est exactement ce qui m'a guidé à
travers mon chemin
pour moi cette maîtrise et se court sur
la décroissance ont été mon premier
petit pas ça a été celui de d'apprendre
et de comprendre le fonctionnement notre
système est d'aller à la découverte de
notre modèle de fonctionnement comme
l'économie sociale le monde des
coopératives des obnl
l'autogestion l'intelligence collective
les écovillages les écoquartiers et j'en
fasse parce que oui il existe beaucoup
d'autres façons de faire et repenser ce
système beaucoup plus qu'on pense
et finalement ce power et pour continuer
enfin se paumer guider vers le deuxième
celui de l'exploration
vivre l'expérience de l'alternatif je
suis allé vivre dans des écovillages
travailler en vo film sur des fermes
biologiques
je suis vraiment parti à l'aventuré pour
rencontrer ces gens qui vivent autrement
ce 3 mon troisième place a été celui de
l'implication
m'engager davantage sur ce chemin du
changement
et ça a été de devenir ambassadrice de
l'économie sociale à travers différentes
universités
ça a été de participer au forum social
mondial à montréal avec des gens
extraordinaires
ç'a vraiment été de co-créer des
conférences pour parler et partager
l'information
qui m'avait permis d'ouvrir les yeux
et finalement m'amener à ce quatrième
pas celui de leur création
est vraiment amené à me demander qu'est
ce que j'ai envie de créer dans le monde
parce que pour moi la création c'est
reprendre possession de ses moyens
et ça a été de créer la première
coopérative en ingénierie au québec avec
sept autres personnes passionnées
une coopérative qui revoit nos façons de
travailler
notre façon de concevoir le monde
qui dit que pour avoir une semaine
normale de travail
on peut faire 20 heures par semaine
une coopérative
qui décident de rallier ingénierie
sociale et environnement et qui voit
chacun de ses membres comme patron de
son organisation
créée ça aussi été pour moi de mettre au
monde le projet changer de cap une
tournée à travers le québec pour filmer
différentes initiatives
inspirante dans le but d'alimenter des
conversations des discussions et
d'inspirer les jeunes des cégeps
québécois
créé pour moi c'est aussi tout
simplement
bâtir un milieu de vie qui
qui me fait du bien qu'il nourrit et qui
est vraiment allié avec mes valeurs
et ce poids de la création est
directement
alimentés par ma curiosité
ma soif d'apprendre et cette envie
d'acquérir de plus en plus de
compétences qui me tente verts qui me
permettent de andres vers l'autonomie
que ce soit à travers la permaculture
pour jardiner en symbiose avec la nature
ou même étudier les propriétés des
plantes
les herbes pour apprendre à me guérir
par moi même ou même la méditation le
développement personnel pour prendre
soin de ma santé mentale mais surtout
m'accompagner dans tous ces changements
de paradigmes intérieur
ou même la communication consciente la
communication non violente qui qui me
donne vraiment une philosophie de vie
qui me permet d'apprendre à m'exprimer
dans le respect de moi et de l'autre
et tout ça pour quoi
finalement
pour m'amener à me transformer
puis c'est vraiment intéressant parce
que en préparant à venir ici j'ai
énormément connecteur à cette notion de
la transformation
qui se retrouve partout en fait
dans la nature
en ou en vous au début comme à la fin
c'est pas pour rien qu'on dit rien ne se
perd rien ne se crée tout se transforme
et ce qui m'a amené à me demander cette
question
qu'est ce que vraiment fait en sorte que
j'ai osé
me lancer dans le vide
et c'est ça
accepter de me transformer moi même et
avoir confiance dans ce processus
c'est la clé
et en plus c'est ce que ces frelons le
plus simple partir de soi pour
déconstruire tout nos paradigmes
intérieur qui après coup enclencherait
cette transformation du système en
lui-même
[Musique]
si vraiment le chemin que je décide de
marché celui de la cohérence intérieur
et extérieur
extérieurs intérieurs et extérieurs
jeter dans le contraire
donc
pour aller plus loin et plonger dans
cette
dans cette volonté de cohérence
et sachant que la transformation prend
place à tous les niveaux j'ai vraiment
revue à travers mon parcours cette
notion ce concept du travail
bon on s'entend c'est pas nécessairement
un concept est assez concret
j'ai parfois l'impression qu'on connaît
pour travailler et je demande c'est ce
qui m'a amené à me dire waouh au québec
le travail fait vraiment sûr que c'est
ce qui fait vraiment trop ce que le
système fonctionne tel qu'il est
son travail
est ce qui aurait vraiment la croissance
économique
est justement en décidant d'aller
plonger plus loin et d'aller à la racine
de ce mot ce mot travail qui provient en
fait du verbe travailler
et qui est lui lui même dérivé du latin
tripalium qui signifie torture est
bon et qui est lui dérivé du mot
tripalium qui dézingue l'instrument de
torture
bon alors comme comme plusieurs ici
j'étais sous le choc de réaliser
waouh hockey
le système se bat vraiment sur cette
énergie là
parce que dans les mots travailler
travailler on retrouve originalement
cette notion de torture de souffrance de
douleur et de domination
ce qui m'amène à imposer comme qu'elles
sont mais moi ok
moi abriel ou est ce que j'ai envie de
deux mètres mais énergie et avec quelle
intention
et justement dans cette dans cette
intention de le faire un pauvre vers ce
changement de paradigme
est ce qui serait pas mieux de planté la
graine de la collaboration
de la contribution
de l'oeuvre
et j'ai vraiment envie de vrai dans la
vie
j'ai l'impression c'est ce que je fais à
travers mon chemin mais soucier c'est
mon histoire
vous ou es ce que vous avez envie de
vrais
est pour vous le rappeler
comme dirait lao tseu un voyage de
milieux commence toujours par un premier
pas merci
[Applaudissements]